sounds to me at this stage that I know
you're speaking on behalf of women but
it sounds that's what you said but it
sounds like she's not I'm speaking on
behalf of myself
you said that you're speaking on behalf
of women it sounds to me like you're
speaking more on behalf of yourself I am
I've never said I was speaking about
last one but so let's go back to my
original question okay you said every
woman deserves to be coated okay yes now
if a man my own opinion right but if a
man but you've also said courtship
obviously being dating without sex but
you've also said that women and men can
date and you've you just agreed recently
a man and a woman can it can lead to a
relationship if a man and a woman has
sex while they're dating so why the [__]
is a man gonna waste all of it why is a
man gonna waste all of those all of
those resources that time and energy on
courting you with no guarantee of six at
the end when you can just date you have
six at the same time and get the same
loyalty and sustainable at the end
thank you